at the dawn of the Industrial Age the  power of the Machine granted us a great  abundance but despite our prosperity we  desired more and our greed became  bloodshed war raged for decades  fouling the air and poisoning the land  light of our achievements faded  from the darkness arose the disappeared  countries of the Asia Empire  the Anglian Republic Marauders are the  frozen ruins the proud desert warriors  of the Arashi League the Vigilant Order  of Canada guardians of the natural world  the ruthless operators of the mercantile  guild  Forgotten ability up  now at the crossroads of a new age we  must once again choose our destiny after  centuries of Darkness the spark of  mankind Flint's